- It's very clear to me
that over the next 15 years,
what the blockchain will do,
especially in the NFT
form on top of Ethereum
is create a world that will
eat up all of the contracts,
all of them.
Every contract over the
next 15 to 25 years,
will be done on the blockchain.
Now, that doesn't eliminate
the need for what we do here,
but it definitely requires
for you to understand it.
(upbeat music)
(man screaming)
- [Narrator] You've got your perspective.
(crowds cheering)
- I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Morning, Atlanta.
(crowds cheering)
It's really, really nice
to be with all of you.
I don't have a ton of time on stage,
'cause I got to run to the meet and greet.
So, I wanna really get
into a bunch of things
that are on my mind for this sector.
Try to bring as much value as
I can while we're together.
I think much like two
years ago when I was here,
how many people were here for that?
(crowds cheering)
Thank you.
It's really interesting,
I really play in two very opposite places
when it comes to
business, life philosophy,
all of it really,
which is so much of what
I do and think about
and what I admire and see in others
is a remarkable level of consistency
of what is truly tried and true.
And then on the complete
other extreme part,
I really spend almost all my time,
trying to understand the one thing
that connects everybody in this room,
regardless of what
they're trying to achieve,
whether you're in this room
and under the context of this room,
you're clearly trying to achieve something
from a professional lens.
But the reality is if you're
passionate about fundraising
for your kid's school or if
you wanna segway your career
or if you've got a side hustle
or if you decide to pivot
or run for public office,
there's just such a fascinating thing
that has always been true,
which is attention is the asset
and how you fill that attention,
becomes the variable of what happens.
I was born in the Soviet Union
and came to the US when I was three
and grew up in the 80s
during the Cold War.
And I've always wondered
if because of that,
I've always had an extra
interest in the media,
in propaganda, in communication,
because that was so much the
warfare of the Soviet Union
and the US and obviously
I don't have to explain
to anybody in this room.
I think over the last half decade,
our society started paying
a lot more attention
to communication.
I was always fascinated by why
if there was a coup in a country,
would they go to the TV station
and the newspapers even before
they went to the palace.
And it made me always understand
that this shit is important.
Communication is the variable.
What's really fascinating
about this industry.
And I have many friends in it,
is when trying to grow the business,
most of the DNA in this room is sales DNA,
it's not brand DNA.
You're not marketing, you're selling.
It's why Google does so well.
It's why so many people
here feel comfortable,
allocating money to Google AdWords,
because it's transactional.
Somebody types something in,
you spend dollars on
it, you go to the top,
you see and feel the ROI very quickly.
I understand it.
I love selling stuff.
It's very easy to understand.
It's very easy to invest in.
What's impossibly difficult
to invest in is brand.
It's hard.
Why am I wearing these?
Because a brand,
nobody knocked on my fucken door and said,
"Do you wanna buy these Nike's?"
I didn't type in Nike into it and then,
this is brand.
This little swoosh is
worth a trillion dollars,
a trillion.
And so I think about that,
because it's easier to
understand with Nike,
but it's harder for a lot
of people in this room
to think about it from
their business lens,
though, we see it.
Many of you know,
many of you have your
faces on billboards and ads
and newspapers and things of that nature.
I believe in all that,
I just don't believe in
overpaying for yesterday
and not investing in today.
Like, whatever you did to
get here was about attention.
Whether it was shaking hands
and having friends and
working the local thing,
whether word of mouth is just attention.
You did something for Craig
and he liked it enough.
And when Sally asked him, he referred,
it's all just the same game.
The problem is
and the thing that I have
had an enormous amount
of passion on is if attention is the asset
that grows everything,
that creates the result,
why aren't people interested
in investing the 20 hours
that it would take to understand
the current space of attention?
Like I just don't understand why
you wouldn't see through the
curiosity and spend five hours
to understand why a TikTok
video might actually lead
to a customer.
I don't understand why you would say no,
let me rephrase it.
I very much understand why you say no.
You say no,
because you positioned it in
your head as something else.
You've positioned it as the thing
that your kids spend all
their time on, right?
But what you don't do is the homework
that makes you understand
that over the last 18 months,
the growth of 35 to 55 year olds on TikTok
is so extraordinary,
we haven't seen growth
of consumption like that,
since 2011 Facebook.
All of a sudden, if you
understand that truth,
it at least leads to the curiosity.
How many people here are
producing three pieces
of TikTok video a day for their business.
And if you raised your hand,
I'm gonna check on stage
publicly, so don't lie.
(crowd laughing)
How many people in this entire room,
make three TikTok videos
a day for their company?
Raise your hands,
two.
I'm sorry, three, sorry, Sally.
Three, three.
I love it and I love the passion of that.
What excites me about that
is because I've been
making content about TikTok
for two and a half years,
I already have dozens of emails
from lawyers, contractors,
a cement provider hit me up last week
that he landed a big
contract from a TikTok.
Do you know how insane it sounds
to even say that a cement provider,
landed a six-figure
contract from a TikTok?
Even for me as progressive
and curious and in it as I am,
I understand how far
fetched that may feel,
but it's a reality.
And this isn't a talk to say,
everybody run out and go make TikToks.
This is a talk of,
are you challenging yourself
to do branding work?
Because it's the singular
thing that grows anything.
Branding is the singular
It's just the way the world works.
And so, I think the
opportunity is extraordinary.
One more time by show of hands,
by show of hands how many people
produce two original videos
or written articles a day on LinkedIn?
Raise your hand.
One, one, two, got you.
Two,
again, that one I struggle with way more,
but it goes back to my only
interest in this talk today.
Why are we, the world,
this is not just this
sector, this is the world.
Why are we not interested
in putting in the 20 to 30 hours
to understand something
that's happening today?
LinkedIn for the last four years
has converted itself into
being the business Facebook.
This is not the LinkedIn
we all grew up with.
LinkedIn Marketing isn't
spamming people on email.
It is making content to go in the feed.
How many people here
consume content on LinkedIn
and know what I'm referring
to raise your hands,
raise it high.
Please, I want you to
raise it higher, come on.
Look.
That is the fun thing for me.
Almost half this room is consuming it.
Two people are making for it.
It speaks to the thing I
started this talk with.
I believe this room is
in the sales business
and I believe if you can make the shift
to understanding that you
need to be in the marketing
and brand business,
it's the only thing that
can substantially double,
triple, 10X a business, it's real.
It's what happens.
It happens at every business,
it's happened for the last 20 years
as we've lived through
the internet revolution.
This is important talk
for a much more important
reason for this specific room.
The reason it's an
important talk for this room
is if you became an operator
of contemporary marketing
for your business in this room,
you would start the process
of changing your perspective
on how you navigate your business life,
which is about to become
unbelievably important
to everybody in this room,
because of the advent of the blockchain.
As we are going into this next tier,
I think all of us
looking around this room,
man, this is a perfect
age demo for the most part
of many people either
never knowing anything else
or the majority of the
room based on what I see,
many of us remembering the
world before the internet
and watching what it's
done over the last 25 years
to change our society.
How many people here made
it through high school,
without being on the internet?
Raise your hands.
I'll raise mine,
raise it high,
that's right kids it sucked.
(crowd laughing)
So, it's a lot of hands in this room.
We recall the world changed a lot.
The world's changed a
lot in the last 25 years.
The biggest companies
of the world changed,
consumer behaviors changed,
the way we buy things has changed,
the decisions we make changed.
And now we have decentralized
servers brewing.
And I'm sure at this point,
especially because this
has been the year of NFTs
and Bitcoin,
most people at this point have heard
of the blockchain, Bitcoin, NFTs,
but I'm also empathetic
that most people have not
spent their 20 to 50 hours
to really understand it.
But let me give you a simple statement
that I genuinely believe will be true
and I think has a lot to
do with this industry.
If with one is to
understand the blockchain.
And in 1995 when I saw the internet,
I realized that my dad's
one liquor store needed
to be an internet retailer,
'cause that's how I was gonna
help my family business.
And even though I didn't own a computer,
I launched one of the first
e-commerce businesses.
And then I did it again with social
and that's kind of how I've navigated.
It is very clear to me that
over the next 15 years,
what the blockchain will do,
especially in the NFT
form on top of Ethereum
is create a world that will
eat up all of the contracts,
all of them.
Every contract over the
next 15 to 25 years,
will be done on the blockchain.
Now, that doesn't eliminate
the need for what we do here,
but it definitely requires
for you to understand it.
And so for me,
this talk is kind of really interesting,
because it reminds me of a talk,
a little bit of a different timing,
but I gave a talk to the
limo and car industry,
right as Uber was happening.
And the majority of my talk was about Uber
in the first 15 minutes.
And as you can imagine,
the crowd didn't like it.
And I was telling them
that I was concerned,
because the iPhone had
become the remote control
of our society and now it really is.
And that I thought it was
dangerous and people poo-pooed it.
They said that legally,
it wouldn't happen or
this wouldn't happen.
Or why would people,
people liked the way it feels to drive,
all excuse after excuse after excuse
and I'm sure everybody realizes,
how much Uber has changed that industry.
I remember talking cause
I had a wine store in 1995
and fell in love with the
internet as this is gonna be big.
And legitimately had two
separate conversations
at the New Jersey
Chamber of Commerce event
in Springfield, New Jersey in 1996
with two bookstore owners who
completely poo-pooed Amazon.
I mean, Amazon probably sold more books
in the last hundredth of a second,
than those two businesses
combined did in five years.
We are very, very, very
good of having opinions,
based on our own financial self-interest.
My friends, you are sitting,
how many people here are retiring
within the next 10 years?
And I don't,
before you raised your hands,
'cause the lady that threw
her hand up quick is exactly,
I mean fast,
you threw that up fast.
Let me get this next part out.
I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and buy an island.
I mean you're old and you're finished.
(crowd laughing)
Raise your hands 10 years, raise it high.
Just wanna get a sense.
All right.
So, there's about seven to 15.
For the rest of you that are not retiring
in what you do for a living.
You have a choice to make in
one man's humble point of view
that could be quite
remarkable in my opinion.
You are in an industry that collaterally
is going to be massively
effected by the blockchain,
because of how peer to peer
contracts are gonna work,
which takes a lot of things in the middle,
out of the equation.
This doesn't have to be bad,
much like I told my friend
who was in the medallion business in LA,
I said, you could invest in Uber.
You could do this.
You could build a fleet
and build a business development thing.
This isn't about technology,
putting people out of business.
Everybody always thinks
about it too extreme.
There'll be lawyers,
even with the blockchain,
doing everything you're doing
for the rest of everyone's career here.
The opportunity though
to completely change the
trajectory of your career
and gain extraordinary market share,
because you actually
understand what's going on
with Ethereum or Solana
or decentralization
or the SCCs point of view on this,
is it a royalty, is a
collateral, is it an asset
is stunning.
I'm one human being and then the last
and yes, I'm in it,
but I'm one human,
in the last six weeks,
I've had multiple dozens,
which is a lot, one person,
dozens of friends asking
for legal and tax help
with the aggressive behavior
in a positive for them
of buying NFTs and what do they
do and how do they navigate?
I just want you to make
LinkedIn posts and TikToks,
because I think your business will grow,
better than the stuff you're doing
with your time and money now.
I am far more motivated
that just three people from this talk,
I'm at the point in my career
where I'm here for a singular reason,
for three of you to email
me in five years and say,
"I don't know if you
remember in 2021 in Atlanta,
"you gave that talk and I took
it serious and I'm now this,"
that feels nice, I like that.
That's how I roll now.
And so I'm telling this room,
this is really happening,
like really.
And the opportunity is extraordinary.
This isn't a fear combo
of like, "Be careful."
This is an optimism combo of,
"Do you understand how big this is?
"Do you understand just
like what the internet did
"to our society over the next 25 years,
"decentralized servers
"that scale are gonna
completely change the world."
Let me ask you a common sense question.
If this was some small shit,
do you think China would ban it?
My friends this is big, big,
this the single biggest
thing that has happened,
since the internet itself.
Social media was a monster
thing in the middle,
because communication
dictates everyone's decisions.
It was big and that's why
I part committed to it.
But this blockchain
thing for this industry
is extraordinarily big because
it's gonna touch it fast.
And so I would highly
recommend people spend
their 20 to 50 hours to get educated
on what a Ethereum is and what
a smart contract looks like.
Because I have a funny
feeling if you actually do,
not just write it on a
piece of paper right now
and then never actually
do anything about it.
If you actually put in the 20 to 50 hours,
I think there's a ton of gold
at the end of that rainbow.
More importantly,
you have five years to go on offense
with what I'm talking about.
If you do nothing in that five years,
your year six from 10 is
gonna be defense on it.
And that's what always happens.
So, that's the big elephant
in the room/opportunity.
The other really interesting part
is how do you get your marketing game up
to grow your business?
And I think that sits in
a very interesting place
of the common mistake of
the last decade of companies
of this size entrepreneurs, executives,
individuals in this room of this size
has been to outsource that behavior,
without being able to judge if it's good.
The reason a lot of you
have your opinion on social
is because you hired your
niece or someone that sucked,
but you had no idea how to judge it.
The ROI of a basketball for LeBron James
is a billion dollars.
The ROI of a basketball
for me is negative $8,000.
I've torn both my knees.
(crowd laughing)
The ROI of social media
is in the trillions.
If it hasn't worked for you,
it's because you don't know how to use it.
20 to 50 hours,
I don't know if you've heard.
There's a site that can
really help you get educated.
I'll give it to you.
I will let you write it down.
It's G-O-O-G-L-E.com.
How does a lawyer make LinkedIn content
that works for their business?
Enter.
(air whooshing)
How do I make a podcast
that brings me business?
Enter.
(air whooshing)
The world is very obvious right now,
everything because of
technology on a daily basis
is getting commoditized,
besides the human aspect
and communication.
Your ability to communicate
to your potential customers
is singularly the variable of your upside.
If I'm able to just use this time together
to get you to realize
you've been in sales mode,
even when you've been doing marketing
and that or when you've been
doing marketing in the past.
And obviously everyone
here does different things
that the modern version of it
is just more effective for the cost.
The problem is people don't
wanna make the investment,
into the cost of creative.
People don't wanna invest in
the videos and the pictures,
they wanna run the ads,
because they're accustomed from Google.
Well, you just run math, right?
You just run the ads, it just words.
In social, the world we live in now,
the ad matters.
Whether that stars you or it does it,
the creative is the variable of success.
LinkedIn ads work
ridiculously well for lawyers,
but there are thousands of lawyers
that have emailed me
over the last five years
that have gotten no ROI.
And the 13 times I've looked
at the link that they sent me
in those 10,000 emails.
It's because the ad sucks.
It's because they're awkward on video,
it's because it wasn't compelling.
It's because it was somebody
trying to throw a right hook,
without setting up a jab.
This is about bringing
value to the other person
on the other side.
You guys have so much knowledge,
you can make videos of just information,
what ifs,
you could do what if scenarios
in video form for the rest of your life,
you've seen it.
You've been through it.
That what if is a piece of
information that might make
the other person feel a
little more comfortable
that you're not just trying to sell them.
Costumers are used to
television ads for lawyers
that have phone numbers that is spam
and direct response creative.
The opportunity is enormous.
We continue for some reason
to disrespect technology.
I'd really prefer you don't.
It makes absolutely no
business sense whatsoever.
Your ideology has nothing
to do with the way you run your business.
People are like,
"Well, Gary, I don't buy
stuff from Facebook ads.
"I'm like, that's great Harold,"
(crowd laughing)
"but fucken 3 billion people do dick.
"Well, Gary, I don't like Facebook.
"It's fake."
I'm like, "Cool.
"Do you like your business?"
Like, what's the matter with people.
If this room doesn't
figure out a Ethereum fast
or if Ethereum becomes Friendster
and something later became
Facebook for social media.
If you don't understand the
concept of smart contracts
on decentralized blockchain,
it will affect your business
in the next 10 years.
The seven people that raised their hands,
you can chill a little bit,
'cause you're gonna be golfing
and drinking margaritas.
The rest of you need to really focus
on 20 to 50 hours of
curiosity and homework.
Stop making assumptions.
I love everybody has an opinion on NFTs
that they're a scam or their beanie babies
or it's a fad without
doing an hour of homework.
We have become a headline
reading hot takes society
that's a bad strategy for actual business.
I think you should change it.
And I hope these minutes
together at least gave you
a little something to push it through.
And I appreciate all of you so much.
I wish you well, thank you.
(crowds cheering)
Thank you.
YouTube watcher, what's up?
It's Gary Vee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you,
please subscribe because my commitment
and exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories,
polls, more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.